les heures passées devant son écran
johnny a du mal à les compter peut-être
16 ou 17 heures par jours confie-t-il
des heures à travailler à développer son
site internet
jouer en ligne écoutez de la musique
jazz classique arabe comme ici ipséité
de dams au la chanson qui l'a inspiré
pour réaliser le drapeau n'est pas aux
allemands m'ont marqué mon choqué et
c'est un peu grâce à elle que qui est
venu tout le processus de création
le mot x et étudiants quelqu'un qui
reste authentique
malgré kiné qui est subi tous les aléas
de la vie tout simplement
diplômé en design graphique et médias
numériques johnny est un artiste mordus
du crayon depuis de nombreuses années ça
a commencé dès que je suis tout petit
j'ai commencé à dessiner très très tôt
et d'un prof ma professeure d'histoire
elle est un petit peu lassé de me voir
dessiner tout en coin elle m'a elle m'a
informé qu'il y avait une filiale de
design qui de communication visuelle à
cette époque qui ouvrait olp de deux
techniques et du coucher
je suis rentré depuis c'est le compte à
rebours pour réaliser le drapeau il a
fallu plusieurs semaines de recherches
sur la caraïbe la souche africaine et la
martinique
un travail de fond élémentaire mais pour
créer l'inspiration il la trouve surtout
dans la nature la nature est pour moi un
moteur de vie quand j'ai besoin de me
ressourcer
je vois ton ici j'ai créé ipséité pour
pour rassembler le peuple en fait j'ai
j'ai voulu quitter soit soit une emblème
de paix un emblème de pacifisme est bon
de constater qu'il crée il crée une
polémique
bon ça m'attriste un peu mais je prends
je prends cette polémique comme étant
une motivation
sam espiau d'autres projets pour essayer
de dd de contribuer à faire évoluer la
martinique vers le futur meilleur
polémique ou pas c'est bien ipséité qui
représentera la martinique à
l'international lors des compétitions
sportives ou des événements culturels
ah oui bon c'est clair que quand je vois
mon drapeau qui flotte dans le vol je
suis je suis content le sourire je me
dis c'est bien je suis satisfait mes
parents ont littéralement sauté de joie
ils étaient contents et pour moi des
moments que mes parents sont heureux je
suis